Nibbana
in the end the bullet that was
everything I feel like Gina has proven
herself as a kick-butt hero how are we
gonna get her in the Marvel Universe
well everybody did it so you could just
pick a character and just step on in
there good you know we they killed
everybody
you could be iron woman miss yeah cuz
who is it iron iron yeah no no we need
to listen to Anthony's I'm really bad
with comic books I'm really bad but I
just think it's time you just proved
yourself so well in this I mean talk
about training for this because I don't
know if I could hold the gun the way
that you did what were your workouts
like was Joe involved did he had to step
it up you just all of it yes like Joe
took me down his path of training and
he's a hardcore athlete so that was
definitely a world I had never entered
into like to that extent it was strict
diet it was working out seven days a
week wait 20 hours a day it's a
lifestyle I don't think I want to do
it's a lifestyle I'm not gonna do
however again no kidding definitely for
a character you know but that's what you
go through and the cool thing is is
having the opportunity to go through it
because to be honest if I miss ball I
probably wouldn't put myself through
that because it was so strict you stay
like this but like I don't stay I didn't
stay like that that was a lot that way a
lot it's funny when we first met we had
never come across each other's paths or
anything but I'm in a gym doing my thing
at the little hotel and she comes in the
gym and it's her and her friend and they
walk in I was like oh they're working
hardcore sweaty just like so I'm on a
treadmill like jeez
Hey how's it going
so many twists and turns and just you
will stop at nothing to save your
friends and family but what message do
we hope us audiences get from this film
because we know that this was an
original spanish-language film I hope
everyone has fun I've always wanted to
action I know Anthony is just bahama in
action so I got really lucky to be able
to play with him but I've always wanted
to action this is my first action film
taking it on I'm very proud of the fact
that you know our community made it and
when I say our community I mean the
entire Latin next community Mexican
Puerto Ricans American Colombian
Argentinian Dominican and so what was
beautiful about that is that like that's
very rare that was a very exciting
experience so I hope that they walk away
having fun and also the studio's saying
that yeah it's time I make you know or
with everyone running with Gina like put
other Latinos and latinas in front of
the camera and put them on your films
and happen to be your leads because we
are capable and we can do it and that's
just that it's very exciting to me to
show that we made a really fun action
well we just got fun I do kind of feel
like a sequel may be brewing with Gloria
and Jimmy because the CIA needs Gloria
is that something you're talking
gloriani's the CIA the Gloria need the
CIA yes how would you like to see that
story play out if there was a sequel I
think Jimmy
becomes like a captain or a sergeant and
he
comes really fat loses he eats a lot of
really good Mexican food and chills out
and he just sends her on missions
Oh again yeah and he used to smoke like
Mexican cigars and eat really good
Mexican food and you call and you're
like I don't know what's going on you're
like figure it out you know I'm I
finally made it to Dame status punch I
don't want to see you guys get together
again okay so we're having a week of
celebrating Marvel women in the MCU so I
want you to tell me your favorites story
of a female a strong female Marvel
character out of Cobie Smulders oh
whatever I just Kobe I love coke you
just love there's a curve just her she's
like strong mom like woman entrepreneur
wife awesome person like just ever great
talent just everything about her I just
want to put in a basket and like give to
the world she's amazing she's dope she's
my happy place
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]